one more thing he's an amazing drummer
do you know that no i do know that i saw
you know i saw a video dad drummer
what's a dad drummer dad drummer means
you know you can play cover songs and
stuff like that but no used to see some
of these the kids today i have to tell
you i saw a video that caroline showed
me that jeremy is a huge fan of his and
he put up this video
jeremy made a fan he's this guy that
works for me put up a video
show him the video and it has like over
a hundred thousand views what is it
okay you gotta stop stop it
all right so what i was doing
dude the internet is amazing
so what i was doing was i was
i was talking about the drummer in um
no no no i just that that that's
metallica meshuggah but sugar
so that song is called bleed it's about
a a brain hemorrhage and i was just
talking about
um i love that a heavy metal band called
themselves meshuggah for those that
don't know that's a very yiddish crazy
it's crazy and yiddish which is crazy in
itself that takes away the edge of for
me of a metal band but go ahead so there
was just something where it was like it
wasn't you know i i don't know much
about drums but they play like two time
signatures against each other three
against four or whatever whatever the
hell he's playing he was playing four on
top and underneath he was playing a
different time signature with his feet
that the band was locked into but the
crowd was locked into what he was doing
with his hands it was the sickest thing
i had ever seen and it's still grooved
and people could still intellectually
wrap their head around it because he had
that four four pulse on top
um and then might as well be talking
and then the singer was singing it for
it was it was it was it was amazing what
was this was so cool was i went to that
show
um dave elich
uh amazing drummer incredible drum
teacher and uh he's going dude you got
to see these guys you got to see this
guy and uh thomas hockey i always say
his last name wrong is the drummer so i
went down there and like every drummer
that i loved was at that show because it
was like watching like david tell comes
to town and we all want to go see david
tell this is the drumming version of it
so they were all there and um
i remember at one point something crazy
happened in a song and danny carey was
there from tool he's one of my favorite
drummers and he's like
super tall right right and something
crazy happened where it was i don't know
they lopped up an eighth note here
something happened you thought the whole
thing was gonna tumble on itself and
they came out on one and it was amazing
right as it happens like what the [ __ ] i
just happened to look over at him this
giant guy and i just saw him just go
[ __ ]
like that i was just like wow they just
blew danny carey's mind that is so cool
that i just saw that i have no idea what
you're talking about
so anyway but i'm sure that you led me
down that road no no no but it's okay
i'm sure in the drumming world it means
something i don't know a lot it's fun to
see a guy
a guy as good as danny carey
you know geeking out about another
drummer
you know you just see like okay so i
find drumming fascinating my son is a my
son could drum jeremy there you go well
he probably enjoyed the story he did i
wish his microphone i know the only
drummer i really know he has a
microphone his microphone's on do you
understand the story jeremy or alex oh
yeah yeah i know everything you're
talking about
okay so it's a good show then i don't
understand it it doesn't matter we have
an audience it's not only about us it's
the people are going you gotta hear we
talked about aviation we talked about
losing an eighth or whatever it was
dropping an eighth note
i know nothing about music and yet i
don't either i don't know yeah you do
did you want it is that what you wanted
to do did you want to be a rock i knew i
did i knew i wanted to have a fun job
but i knew
one of the things that i was blessed
with was i always knew that if if i
didn't have it i knew early i knew if i
sucked at something and i remember with
like drums it was you know playing and
everything
you know i had a basic level
understanding and talent for it but then
i i just would go to these music stores
and i would see some eight-year-old kid
and i would see that he had the gift and
i just knew i was just like this is this
is not my calling i you know same way
like i got into construction i you know
i tried to do that it's like i like
pickup trucks you know i like breaking
balls maybe i can do
maybe i can do construction i just
didn't
i'm smart enough that if you if you tell
me what to do but like i didn't have a
gift for it so comedy was the only thing
i remember the first night i walked in
when you started like the 90s 92 it
wasn't the first night because the first
night was a
like a a contest so it's just
you know the first open mic show i went
to was the comedy club stitches i don't
know if you ever played it in boston
yeah i did it does not exist anymore so
i remember walking in there
and as nervous as i was i felt at home
where i'd finally found the people that
were the same kind of weird i was
[Music]